killer dolls demonic nuns and sadistic
clowns while we may take it for granted
that every superhero adventure has more
to come other continuations might
surprise you these 13 horror classics
are slated for a sequel
valak is back baby the Demonic nun has
been haunting The Conjuring Universe
ever since a second film in the
franchise is getting her very own sequel
the none terrorized audiences back in
2018 scaring up a whopping 365 million
dollars across the globe screenwriter
Aquila Cooper is going to pen the script
for the nun too the film will take place
in 1950s France with Sister Irene of the
original nun being summoned to sub-valux
Killing Spree Bonnie Aarons is set to
reprise her role as a demonic villain
the ISA Farmiga will be back his sister
Irene and storm Reed has been cast in a
lead role as a nun
in that current age of sequels remakes
and reboots of what can sometimes feel
like every significant film ever made
revisiting one of the most iconic horror
films of all time was all but inevitable
and sure enough a new Trilogy is in the
works the original Exorcist centered on
a 12 year old girl played by Linda Blair
it was possessed by a terrifying demon
her mother played by Ellen burstin hires
two priests to perform an exorcism
although both priests died in the
original film burstin will be repricing
her role aiding new protagonist Leslie
Odom Jr as he searches for help with his
own possessed child
want to play a game well jigsaw
certainly does then a Troy your serial
killer is coming back in August 2022 it
was announced that saw X will arrive in
theaters on October 27 2023 but recently
just got moved up to September 29 2023.
just in time for Halloween and Tobin
Bell himself the actor who appears as a
jigsaw killer in every installment
except for 2021 spiral will slash his
way back onto the screen the film will
be directed by Kevin grewer who
previously Helms saw six and saw the
Final Chapter
Stephen King has created some truly
scary stories but none are quite as
disturbing as pet cemetery however
there's something irresistible about the
novel and Hollywood keeps returning to
the Insidious story there was a film
adaptation in 1989 followed by a sequel
in 1992. it was then rebooted in 2019
with Jason Clark playing a father who
discovers the woods behind his house can
bring the dead back to life with
terrifying results John Lithgow played
the well-meaning Judd Crandall in the
2019 version the neighbor who foolishly
tells Clark's character about the sour
ground behind his home now we're going
to learn how Judd first discovered the
unhollowed part in Pet Cemetery
Bloodlines something that brings things
back a prequel directed and co-written
by Lindsey beer the film will take place
in 1969 and will show Judd and his
friends banding together to face a
darkness that holds their Hometown under
its sway Jackson white of Hulu's tell me
lies or Star Wars young Judd and he'll
be joined by two acting Legends David
Duchovny of the X-Files and Pam Grier of
Jackie Brown
while the nearly silent acquired Place
stays entirely focused on one small
family the sequel a quiet place part 2
zooms out that film brings a surviving
characters from the first film into
contact with a small peaceful community
that has managed to stay isolated from
the sound-seeking monstrosities prowling
the world around them now a further
choir place film is on the ducky but
Paramount is positioning it as a
spin-off according to deadline writer
director Michael sanarski will oversee a
quiet place day one the leads will be
played by Lupita Nyong'o and Joseph
Quinn of stranger things Fame the young
girl posted a cast photo to Instagram in
March 2023 revealing that g-mon hunso
would return to the quiet place Universe
likely reprising his role as Manon
Island from a quiet place part 2. we
don't know much more about the plots but
we do know that a choir plays day one
wrapped production in mid-april 2023
theatrical release for acquired Place
day one comes on March 8 2024
killer dolls are Master voted culturian
says by combining innocent childhood
play things with evil murder Mayhem and
usually a little comedy following in the
steps of Chucky Annabelle and the boy
comes Megan a high-tech take on the
formula in this film a toy company's
roboticist creates Megan an eerily
life-like doll with sophisticated
Artificial Intelligence on board she's
able to learn and adapt to make life
better for the child she's imprinted
upon in this case the roboticist niece
naturally things go awry and Megan
becomes violently overprotective of her
young charge Megan earned 30 million
dollars in his January 2023 opening
weekend far exceeding industry
prognostications just Days Later
Universal took the early steps to bring
a sequel to the Big Screen Actors Alison
Williams and violet McGraw are returning
for the sequel as is Aquila Cooper who
Penns the original script expect Megan
2.0 to dance into theaters on January 17
hey Katie
Hi Megan
every few years another Cloverfield
movie comes along Cloverfield sequels
have historically been developed under
code names and are revealed to be part
of the popular franchise until their
trailers have the big and small screens
or in the case of 2018's a Cloverfield
Paradox just before the film hit Netflix
on Super Bowl Sunday all three
Cloverfield movies are dramatically
different from one another 2008
Cloverfield is a found footage horror
movie about a stampeding monster 2016's
10 Cloverfield Lane takes place almost
entirely in a bunker and the Cloverfield
Paradox is a space Thriller considering
this history of secrecy it's likely
nobody will know what the fourth
Cloverfield movie is really about until
just before it's released which will be
some time in the next few years
according to the Hollywood Reporter
franchise producer JJ Abrams hired
writer Joe Barton to write the
screenplay in January 2021. in September
2022 Babar Khan Vari landed a director's
job almost everything else about the
movie remains a mystery
in 2005 Hollywood took a gamble on
Constantine based on a relatively
obscure DC Comics title hellblazer Keanu
Reeves portrays the titular John
Constantine a sardonic World weary
Exorcist who can talk to demons and
angels and move back and forth between
Earth and the underworld budgeted as a
steep 100 million dollars Constantine
earned 230 million dollars and the
worldwide box office this doesn't cement
Blockbuster's status but it is enough to
earn a cult following John Constantine
would go on to inspire the short-lived
but well-received 2014 series
Constantine where he was played by Matt
Ryan nearly 20 years after Constantine
hit the Silver Screen Warner Brothers
started to consider making a second film
in September 2022 the deadline reported
that a follow-up was underway Reeves is
set to reprise a role of John
Constantine while original movie
director Francis Lawrence will Helm the
sequel screenwriter Akiva goldsman will
Pender script and produce however when
Warner Brothers DC adaptation department
leaders James gunnon to saffron and
veiled their plans for the next few
years Constantine didn't even Merit a
mention Reeves told Cinema Blend in
March 2023 we're trying I don't know if
it's gonna happen writer Akiva goldsman
gave a semi-positive update in July 2023
telling bingeworthy that he's figured
out the plot for Constantine too but as
he put it I just haven't started typing
yet I need a mirror now at least three
feet high
the 2007 film I Am Legend starred Will
Smith as Robert Neville the seemingly
Soul human Survivor of an apocalyptic
plague that transformed most the world's
humans into a terrifying cross between
zombies and vampires however Neville
eventually encountered another pair of
survivors a woman and a young boy who
were both also immune to the virus the
ending of the film didn't leave a lot of
room for Smith to return for a sequel
since it saw Neville sacrificing himself
in order to save the other two Burton
alternate ending found Neville surviving
and having a darker meaning to the title
I Am Legend according to the original
film's writer Akiva goldsman the sequel
announced in 2022 would follow that
other ending golsman told deadline this
will start a few decades later than the
first we traced back to the original
Matheson book and the alternate ending
what Mathison was talking about was that
man's time on the planet as a dominant
species had come to an end the that's a
really interesting thing we're going to
get to explore Michael B Jordan is set
to headline I am Legend 2 along with
Smith however not long after I am Legend
2 was announced Smith made headlines for
slapping Chris rocker the Oscars putting
the fate of several of his future
projects in Jeopardy since the release
will likely come several years after the
incident it's possible that I am Legend
2 will still go ahead with Smith
attached our swim will actually see
Smith and Jordan meets up we're not
exactly sure speaking with binge-worthy
golsman said that he'd begun writing the
script for ION Legend 2 before the
writer's Guild of America Striker begun
but at the moment the screenplay is on
pause
the rare supernatural horror movie
that's also a 1980s period piece and
something of a buyer pick strong and
oscar-winning actor the Pope's Exorcist
was a solid hit earning a tidy 66
million dollars in Spring 2023 Russell
Crow starts as father Gabrielle armort a
character based on the real person of
the same name who allegedly spent years
casting out demons on behalf of the
Roman Catholic Church the Pope's
Exorcist tells just a small part of our
Mort's story specifically the time
during which he claimed to have expelled
tens of thousands of demons that makes
for a lot of sequel potential and indeed
just two weeks after the Pope sex
assessed at movie theaters screen gems
began development on another movie about
Armor's demon hunting Adventures no word
yet on whether Crow will return to the
role or if the original film's Helmer
Julius Avery is in line to direct the
sequel it's okay Mommy
Henry's okay
not only one of the most consistently
creepy franchises in recent years The
Conjuring universe is also one of the
most lucrative series of any kind raking
in over 2 billion dollars at the global
box office the series is set up by the
70s set horror classic from 2013 about
paranormal investigators Lorraine and Ed
Warren who look into claims of a dark
and evil presence at a spooky rural
Farmhouse the Warrens ghost hunting
continues in 2016's a Conjuring 2. and
2021's The Conjuring the devil made me
do it with plenty more ghost stories to
tell under receptive paying audience
ready to watch them The Conjuring
franchise would expand again with a
fourth movie subtitled Last right
according to the Hollywood Reporter lead
Studio new line is already signed up
David Leslie Johnson McGoldrick who
penned both Conjuring sequels to write
the script for the fourth movie
franchise originating producers James 1
and Peter Safran will also return to
oversee the new film the Vera Farmiga
and Patrick Wilson are once more playing
the roles of the ray and Ed Warren
although we don't know the plot or the
release date more importantly will this
be the final Conjuring movie well when
asked that question in the January 2023
interview with collider Juan responded
you never know we'll see
a horror flick with a familiar format
and an original premise smile is one of
the few non-franchise horror hits of
recent years so successful that it's
probably the first in what will be a
whole series of movies the First full
length feature from writer director
Parker Finn smile Minds Terror and
discomfort out of a usually friendly
facial expression the simple smile
becomes twisted and unsettling when it's
plastered on the faces of those
possessed by an evil presence after
witnessing a college professor's
inexplicable death a student experiences
haunting visions of a creepy smiling
creature verse a string off horrific
smiles and deaths again until crafty
psychiatrist Dr Rose cutter figures out
how and why the evil virus strikes smile
grows 217 million dollars on a
relatively meager budget so it was a hit
in every possible way for Paramount
Pictures when the studio presented its
upcoming slate at Cinema Khan in April
2023 it announced that a sequel to smile
was in its early stages no details were
provided in regards to cast a director a
ice cream ricer or a release date you're
going to die you're going to die
one of the most notable entries in the
Horus sub-genre of killer clown movies
2016's Terror fire indeed terrified
audiences with the gruesome and
murderous actions of art the clown a
dryly humorous prankster not unlike a
mix of Pennywise and Freddy Krueger the
sermon to kill three women on a curse
Halloween evening with an ultra low
budget of 35 000 terrifier enjoyed a
modest rollout only to turn into a cult
classic and prompt a 2022 sequel
terrifier 2. in May 2023 deadline
announced that a third Franchise entry
terrifier 3 would soon Haunt movie
theaters set to start filming in the
final weeks of 2023 terrifier 3
filmmakers are working toward a release
date of sometime in late 2024 as for the
plot writer director Damien Leone
tweeted that terrifier 3 will pick right
up after part two however he also told
variety that it would be more in line
with the tone of the first film the ones
said in the interview I want to shift
back a bit to the tone of par 1 which I
felt was little more simplistic and
old-school gritty slasher I want this
one to go back in that direction and I
want this to be the scariest one of the
trilogy this one will actually have a
little bit more of an evil overtone to
it so this is going to be hopefully the
scariest and the darkest
[Music]